try not to smile to yourself who said
that or kill yourself
who said that anyway try not to smile
just belong here who keeps doing that I
belong to someone else
try not to smile shouldn't exist why do
I exist Wow
the play button has a voice please kill
me
it's almost as innovative as this video
idea
[Music]
well you know what I accept the
challenge
Jesus at odds heavy I accept
[ __ ] kids screams like a girl not even
chuckle you know okay well you know what
this might actually be a girl so excuse
me
Craven underscore 14 for assuming a
little girl's gender even though I
technically just did us don't assume
gender Fox jetpack Oh God I tied just
the title made me hate the video hasn't
started I hey hey
doesn't camp that's a stupid [ __ ]
tight oh it's Fox News I expected a fox
on it well [ __ ] it let's just watch and
I'm live here at the San Diego Yacht &
Boat Show good morning everybody I'm
hanging out with my friend John Fox 5
Morning News starts look over there and
it starts right now
serving all
this is your Fox five minutes oh this is
easy feel free to play along by the way
Fox 5 Morning News starts look over
there and it starts right now all they
had to do was watch over there was that
so hard
look over there clearly he doesn't know
how he has to keep eye contact to the
camera it starts right now
moving on Hercules miss reads a stage
direction as a line oh that's fun that's
funny I haven't watched the video but
that's funny
wait a minute this isn't my world that's
funny
this isn't my world hello honey he's so
into it just Souza border no just
knowing the fact that I will never be
that good a good of an actor makes me
dear boy it doesn't even say it in a
disappointing tone you know what [ __ ] it
I lost that one fine two one bring it
way to go Paul
knew it was coming I knew it was
happening but it still worked
typical Paul typical Paul behavior
[ __ ] Paul [ __ ] that's danger
you know what no it's this hilarious a
handbag
I'm so [ __ ] bad that was not even
that funny let's see what all right now
this this last video we saved the best
for last kill yourself you really have a
comment about everything don't you
mr. septic guy to my latest upload I
don't I don't know how I'm gonna keep
doing the vlog it's just not worth it I
said it before but I never want to force
fun you know I really have a lot of fun
when I'm in my own setup
I need to put myself first this is easy
I'm not gonna smile at this this is so
sad
wait a minute
[Music]
got him well that was another try
natured know there was the first try not
to smile challenge oh man this is says
this channel is just keeps keep going up
thank you for watching
did you leave a smile did you smile
leave a like and that was the deal as
part of the video come on smile a little
bit you have such a cute smile
come on give me give a little smirk come
I know I know you want to I know you
want to come up there it is oh now you
gotta leave a like and thank you for
watching I'll see you Bros in the next
video and as always
[Music]